Suicide Squad was one of the
highest-grossing releases of 2016
setting a new record for the best ever
opening weekend in August and going on
to earn 745 million dollars worldwide
critics however toured apart
calling it quote slipshod and a patch
together mess among other things so how
sloppy is Suicide Squad here are just a
few examples worst part of it is they're
gonna blame us for the whole thing name
changer near the start of the film a
character clearly identified as Admiral
Mackenzie isn't sold on the idea of Task
Force X or is it admiral olsen ted
whittles character wears a name tag
identifying him as Mackenzie which can
be seen several times throughout the
scene but bizarrely when the end credits
roll his character is listed as Admiral
Olsen it was a nice touch to bring
wibble on board hardcourt DC fans will
remember him as suicide squad leader
rick flagg in the final season of
Smallville but the confusion over his
character's name shows how little
importance he actually had in the script
traveling light after extorting his
client for an extra million dollars and
carrying out a near impossible hit
Deadshot makes his escape by jumping
over the edge of the building and
rappelling down the wall but before he
makes a run for it he grabs his big bag
of high-tech gear but what happens next
sticks out like a sore thumb once you
know about it the rucksack he scoops up
as he Sprint's for the ledge is nowhere
to be seen while he's actually
descending it just disappears into thin
air
that's raw uncut Rock kiddie pool when
the Joker dives headfirst into the same
vat of chemicals as his beloved Harley
Quinn there's something off about the
staging would he die for me
yes we see from other shots of the VATS
and shots from below the surface of the
chemicals that the containers are pretty
deep it's definitely deep enough for a
person to jump into it from a great
height and not be killed that's too easy
what are you would you live yet after
the Joker jumps in to rescue Quinn he's
able to cradle her in his arms and kiss
her while standing still which is
impossible unless he suddenly developed
aquaman like swimming powers magic
highlights Harley Quinn is captured by
Batman when a sports car she's in driven
by the Joker goes crashing into the
harbour wanting to take them both alive
the Caped Crusader goes in after them
where he finds the Joker missing and
Quinn unconscious underwater Quinn's
hair is entirely blonde free from the
pink and blue highlights she sports for
the majority of the movie after Batman
pulls her from the water however the
highlights inexplicably returned Moon's
mistakes June moon is an archaeologist
who finds a totem containing an evil
spirit in an ancient Peruvian temple and
is possessed by it becoming The
Enchantress in one scene enchantress
obtains a binder from the weapons
ministry vault in Tehran written in
Persian script it should open and be
read right to left instead of left to
right but Suicide Squad gets it
backwards in a later scene we can see
moon is holding a beer bottle in her
hand as she fiddles with rick flagg
shirt the angle changes as moon leans in
for a kiss and now the bottle is somehow
in his hand
I saw it boom elevator edits during an
error late an elevator a sense Harley
Quinn is attacked by one of
Enchantress's foot soldiers who drops
down into the elevator by removing a
panel in the ceiling Quinn dispatches it
with a bullet to the head and then a
second attacker smashes through the
window too glaring mistakes follow first
the body of the creature she shot dead
seconds earlier just vanishes then
during the second fight Quinn runs up
the wall and flips over her assailant
and when she does
we get a shot of the elevator ceiling
the panel that was removed moments ago
is now back in place a bad day at the
office for the editing team peeping toms
there is another Harley Quinn related
goof during the scene in which the squad
get out of their frizzen rags and get
suited up as she slips into something a
little more comfortable the camera pans
up Margot Robbie's body slowly as if to
mimic the leering of men nearby hardly
anyone is around Quinn as she squeezes
into her daddy's little monster t-shirt
yet in the next shot she's suddenly
surrounded by gawking men a funny reveal
but it makes zero sense what thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel let's
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love to
[Music]